people to judge
Pete bootage Edge has come out in the
wake of a shooting in Colorado which
seemed to Target people for being LGBT
uh Pete bootage
has come out and said he doesn't want
conservatives thoughts and prayers
there has always been a relationship
between the social and political
demonization of a group and that group's
vulnerability to being physically
attacked and it is completely
unacceptable and I don't want to hear
thoughts and prayers from somebody who
has been actively singling out this
group for hate fear and whether they say
so or not ultimately for violence I
don't want your thoughts and prayers you
evil conservatives because you're the
reason that this happened you you
conservatives
are the reason
that this this hateful far-right fascist
conservative right-winger shot up this
gay club
right that's what Pete Buddha judge is
telling you
which is very ironic
because
people to judge and Joe Biden
have four years demonized conservatives
so if people to judge's principle is
that if you criticize a group or if you
invade against a group that you are then
responsible for violence against that
group Then Pete Buddha judge and
especially Joe Biden would have a lot of
blood on their hands Joe Biden has spent
the last six months calling parents
terrorists concerned parents or domestic
terrorists and said
that conservatives are far-right Fascist
existential threats to our democracy
okay but furthermore even the premise of
Pete Buddha judge's whining is and his
his really vicious attack on
conservatives is false because the guy
who shot up the club according to
attorneys according to the news reports
right now was not some far-right Maga
hat wearing conservative guy
he was a member of the LBG the LGBT
community
the guy who shot up the club according
to the attorneys according to the news
reports it identifies as non-binary
so as usual you know I didn't report on
this shooting right when it happened not
because I don't care about the shooting
obviously any shooting is very very sad
but because I just knew that the media
reports were going to be BS in the the
first 24 hours like they always are
on this show we we usually don't have
knee-jerk reactions right to to these
sorts of news stories and the reason for
that is because
after these big events that can be
exploited by political activists there
is a ton of propaganda and you don't
really know what's true and what's not
it's kind of like the war in Ukraine no
one has any idea what is actually
happening in Ukraine because there's a
ton of Russian propaganda and there's a
ton of Western propaganda and a lot of
it is BS don't forget just a a week or
so ago we we were almost on the brink of
World War III because of news reports
that Russia fired a missile into Poland
and then it turned out it wasn't Russia
that fired the missile it was Ukraine
that fired the missile and so the the
idea that this would trigger Article 5
and we had to go bomb the Kremlin
was Preposterous it was actually the
opposite of reality
well same thing here
I just knew that these news reports were
going to be dubious and they were going
to be filled with a lot of propaganda
and that's what's happening now
furthermore though furthermore to Pete's
point
what degree of Pride does it take to say
I don't want your prayers
it just it just takes a lot of pride
pun unintended but pride is the queen of
all vices okay pride is the deadliest of
the seven deadly sins and to say I don't
want your prayers is to say I'll do it
myself I'm good enough in myself I don't
need you I don't need the help of God I
just we should always be praying we
should always be praying we should
always welcome prayers from anybody we
should welcome prayers from our worst
enemies we should pray for our worst
enemies we should all this is a very
very Fallen World okay and the only hope
you've got is is to pray and Pete Buddha
judge doesn't get it and the Democrats
don't get it at all and their their view
of the world is just so backwards and
that pride in that hubris
uh I think conceals for them the
absurdity and the hypocrisy of their
very statement
conservatives are evil fascists terrible
threats to our very democracy they're
terrorists and also if you ever
criticize anybody you're guilty of
committing violence against them
no conservative criticisms legitimate
and they're legitimate criticisms of the
LGBT activist movement that pushes
Dragon Story Hour in schools and tries
to cut off little kids genitals none of
them none of the criticisms that the
right makes of those people
come anywhere close to what Joe Biden
has said
when Joe Biden says conservatives by
your very existence you pose a threat to
our entire country your terrorists
when it doesn't even come close okay so
I just don't want to hear it from people
to judge but I don't want to hear
anything from people to judge as it so
happens hi Michael I'm
one state for Washington I'm not a
hugely religious guy but after having my
children I am firmly against abortion my
question is them my wife when she was 16
had an abortion she was young dumb you
know the girl
the issue is every time I tried to speak
to her about it about abortion in
general she feels like I am judging her
or attacking her which I truly believe
it's her own guilt that she is feeling
and she's judging herself your advice
would be greatly appreciated
how or should I try to talk to her about
it or should I just keep my thoughts to
myself on a fortune thanks Michael
appreciate it
it obviously is her own guilt and it's
such a Preposterous trick women
sometimes do this where if they'll do
something that is very bad and then if
you point this out you know or suggest
maybe you know you shouldn't do that or
whatever they'll say you're attacking me
stop attacking me and then sort of try
to evade the issue or try to invert the
situation but no it's obviously her own
conscience that is nagging at her and so
I don't think you should you know burn
her at the stake or anything like that
but
nor should you allow yourself to be
cowed into pretending that infanticide
is okay plenty of people have had
abortions
plenty and plenty of people have had
abortions okay I know many people and I
know uh my family members have had
abortions you know it's and it's really
awful and some of them have come to
regret them and some of them haven't
come to to regret them consciously at
least uh
the people fall into it it's very easy
to fall prey to that it's very easy to
fall parade of Temptation the only way
though that she's going to have Solace
from it
is to repent you know the first step on
the road to recovery is admitting you
have a problem and so you've got to do
that and I would recommend sacramental
confession uh I I think it is
I I believe there is a Sacrament that
was instituted by our Lord on this Earth
uh which gives priests the power to bind
and loose and to retain sins and to
forgive sins and I think that even if
you don't believe in the spiritual
efficacy of the sacrament of confession
as I do but even if you don't believe in
it the psychological effects of that are
amazing when you actually hear someone
saying in the person of Christ I absolve
you of your sins that really lifts a
huge burden off of people and people
it's amazing with confession because
even
practicing Catholics myself included we
don't want to go to confession usually
because we say oh it's just so
embarrassing I've got to confess my sins
to a priest oh it's just you really
dread the whole thing and then you go
and the priest assert everything before
priest has heard abortionless before
okay I promise you that and and he says
okay I absolve you every sins say oh
what a burden why have I been carrying
that around for weeks and weeks or in
the case of your wife years and years
and years
tell her to do it she's not she's not
going to feel any better by by denying
the issue all right the rest of the show
continues now we have a very good friend
of mine coming on the show today
to talk about a new documentary and one
of the biggest biggest political issues
in America where probably some of the
most important political fights were
taking place that would be at the
schools
the rest of the show continues now if
you are not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]